the former vice president wants an
investigation of the president's phone
call with Ukraine's leader Biden says
mr. Trump is using the presidency to
smear his campaign a new poll shows
Elizabeth Warren taking the lead over
Biden in Iowa where the first Democrats
will cast their votes in February ed
O'Keefe is covering campaign 2020 in
Waterloo Iowa and how's Biden reacting
to the pressure well Anthony good
morning the former vice president
responded angrily to the news over the
weekend but now he's campaigns trying to
spin it to his advantage
saying this proves that the president is
most concerned about running against
Biden in 2020 focus on the violation of
the Constitution this president has
engaged in joining an auto workers
picket line in Kansas City Sunday Joe
Biden pointed the finger back at
President Trump over the weekend the
former vice president slammed the
president over reports he pressured the
Ukrainian leader to investigate
unsubstantiated accusations against
Biden and his son hunter who once served
on the board of a Ukrainian energy
company I'll beat him like a drum Biden
is calling for the house to investigate
but he stopped short of mentioning
impeachment I plan to release the
transcript of the call let everybody
house it and see what he did over the
weekend in Iowa other Democratic
contenders went further we need to
absolutely right away begin impeachment
proceedings he's got to go how many
crimes does this president have commit
before Congress will act and impeach him
and what do you make of this mess with
Ukraine and whistleblower I did not
think the Donald Trump could shock me
anymore
but this behavior
stunning the controversy comes amid
signs of trouble for the Biden campaign
a new poll shows senator Elizabeth
Warren jumping ahead of item by two
points among likely Iowa caucus goers
joining a different auto worker strike
in Detroit Warren brushed off the
numbers what this is about is about a
message that we are sick and tired of an
America that works for a thinner and
thinner slice at the top and isn't
working for anyone else no in another
sign that the Biden campaign is trying
to capitalize on this controversy it is
sent out at least three fundraising
emails to supporters saying that the
president is mounting a misinformation
campaign and that only money will right
this wrong so now why are we here in
Waterloo this morning well we're about
to board the campaign bus of South Bend
Indiana mayor Pete Buda jets to talk to
him about his campaign that poll shows
that he's in fourth place we'll talk
about how he's trying to get the first
about this UK Ukraine controversy his
new health care plan and other issues
you'll see it all tomorrow on CTM I'm
going to answer the question that I was
one of you and Waterloo this morning
Thank You ed O'Keefe always good to see
you